et
[Musique]
d'après moi ça tu sais quoi quand je
vois ça je me dis que nous à paris mon
fils vraiment comme des cours n'a rien
compris
ouattara lors ils sont très amis ça
depuis longtemps
on parle pas trop de ce qu'ils font à
leur vie mais on voit qu'ils sont tu
parle de sexualité que ta fille toi oui
oui oui
soit ces normes ou 40 mais les belles
cartouches
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu apprends à
ta fille se servir d'une arme ouais je
te fais pas et j'ai l'impression que le
couple est assez touchant dans l'amitié
dans le secret qu'il exerce avec moi
bon je n'arrive à
j'ai essayé de jouer le père moderne
c'est à dire le père cool
il n'y a pas de problème passe pour la
tête il faut être proche de ses enfants
[Musique]
et
et je pense que la comédie en tout cas
du côté de l'ocs de personnages allant
bien au delà c'est que c'est un mec qui
a une patate brûlante qu'il est
complètement victimes de la situation
dans laquelle il acceptait de se mettre
alors il ya eu un moment d'égarement
il ya un moment on a le choix je suis
dans ma chambre tu n'es pas longtemps
que tu es donc marc
et maintenant tu vas donc
j'ai tout le temps pensé dès lors qu'on
voulait faire une comédie d'amener mon
personnage dans un état de nerfs
me se mettre dans tous ses états même si
c'est légitime je veux dire que tu as
couché avec un garçon qui tu achetais
mais c'est qui ce ton cul les jetons
qu'elles remplissent bien leur rôle
toutes les deux et notamment la petite
lola le lan avec cette fraîcheur et
cette générosité de s'abandonner dans
cette histoire et puis mon alice c'est
déjà une actrice je dirais presque
chevronnés attend pas non plus tu sors
pas non plus étroite a pas besoin
4e à domicile avec jean-françois il a vu
qu'on avait envie de réussir le film est
donné le mieux qu'on pouvait on vieillit
de plus en plus tard on est tous un peu
atteint de jeunisme
j'espère que le film est en accord avec
notre époque
[Musique]
oh